[Music]
you enjoying the summer so far that yeah
the quest I am I am it's nice it's it's
good to have the kids out of school it
sort of complicates things just in terms
of you have to spend more time with your
kids it's nice I guess what a shitty
thing to say they don't watch this show
yeah it's nice that summers pretty good
although I'm always the way that you and
we're the only ones in suits everyone is
wearing shorts yeah there definitely has
sort of a casual attitude I think all
summer very very casual attitude all
summer long and have you noticed that
Andy like even in our staff people are
sort of start until like I don't know
phone and in a little bit like Steve our
camera guy who isn't wearing any pants
he's wearing no pants
[Applause]
angels fan I think yeah have you seen
the lighting guys with the marshmallows
oh yeah that's a whole day Juna you know
what I've noticed Andy I've noticed my
cue card guy is really phoning it in
he's really not trying that hard you
know yeah okay great yeah all right yeah
that's terrific
yeah that's a lot of help great job yeah
and my assistant sona replaced herself
with a Roomba it's ridiculous where's my
coffee Sona
[Applause]
thank you wait a minute that's actually
working pretty well
like the real yeah up with your hair
hair is cleaning it up
moving on you know I rememba Sona I
don't think I don't think the wardrobe
department is giving a hundred percent
today now they really over there just
yeah it's like you and I are the only
ones keeping it professional Andy you
bet Conan
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll take a break lesson we'll come
back coffee huh this is working fine -
we'll all be on the ball with Lance
Shepherd he's here in his head and stick
around
you